The storms were unlike anything anyone had
ever seen.
But the worst part wasn’t just the deadly
gales, wind howling powerful enough to knock
down buildings like rows of dominoes, and
lift the remaining debris of cities up into
the air as if all that destruction weighed
nothing.
And it wasn’t just the lightning, those
arcs of crimson forking down from above.
If one struck the ground near you – and
one almost always did – the sheer force
of it would knock you off your feet.
The last thing you’d feel as you flailed
helplessly in the air was the relentless pain
of your body being disintegrated by the energy
of the blood-red lightning, until there was
nothing left of you for anyone to find.
Yet, somehow that wasn’t the worst part
either.
And it wasn’t even the noise of it all either,
that deafening cacophony of booming thunder
and wild, hurricane-force winds, so loud nobody
could ignore it, all underscored by the screams
of a world lost in suffering and madness.
No, the worst part of it all was the sky.
Whenever anyone looked up, where there had
once been that clear, calming blue, was now
a swirling mass of nightmares.
Many were surprised just how much they missed
turning to the sky, that odd, universal comfort
it brought, the knowledge that no matter how
bleak things got, the sun would set on every
bad day and rise again to mark the start of
another, filled with potential.
That promise of a future, no matter how uncertain,
was replaced with a reminder of one thing:
that this new, darker day had no end.
There was no sunrise or sunset, no night or
day.
All that uncertainty and potential was replaced
with certain doom, represented by a sky that
looked like a river of blood.
Deep reds and blacks swirled and thrashed
above like the raging waves of the ocean,
casting bolts of lightning down at the Earth…
not to mention what else would occasionally
drop from that bloodstained sky.
Nobody had much information about how this
had all started, how the world had become
such an unrecognizable hellscape.
Cynics would say that the world was already
hell long before the sky turned red, although
there wasn’t much time for sarcastic jokes
like that nowadays.
As far as the few human beings that had survived
could remember, the day everything changed
had been little more than an ordinary day
on Planet Earth.
One moment things were normal, people were
working tirelessly at their boring nine-to-five
jobs, somewhere in the world others had long
since fallen asleep in a different time zone.
Then, all of a sudden, it appeared.
Few survivors had actually seen it for themselves,
and even fewer had lived to tell the tale.
But rumors and whispers spread from camp to
camp, dispossessed people huddled together
in the ruins of houses or in abandoned subway
tunnels would hear the stories.
And somehow, deep down in the fearful recesses
of their hearts, they all knew, despite never
having seen it, that it was real… the Masked
God.
When it stepped upon the earth, it walked
like any other person would; its body even
appeared to be human.
An aged, older man’s body, wrinkled and
elderly, although not completely decrepit.
Yet it was his face, or what covered it, that
really instilled that sense of fear and dread
in anyone that heard the rumors.
The being wore a mask, a porcelain comedy
mask, the kind commonly associated with Ancient
Greek theatre.
It had a fixed, unnerving expression, a wide
smile of twisted glee.
It was almost as if it was getting some sick
enjoyment out of all the chaos and destruction
that had befallen the world…
like it was pleased with its own handiwork.
A thick, black substance oozed from the mask
too, adding to its unsettling appearance as
streaks of what looked like tar trickled down
the chalky white surface.
It leaked out from underneath as well, dripping
over the bony shoulders of the old man that
wore it.
Not one survivor that heard the stories of
this monster understood what it was or where
it had come from, but – as if by some deific
influence – they all knew it was responsible
for creating the hell they now lived in.
That knowledge kept them hidden, kept them
afraid… and kept them from fighting back.
As had always been the case, even before this
apocalypse had been unleashed on the world,
the only people who knew the truth were those
who had been working for the SCP Foundation.
They had more than their fair share of answers
about what had happened, and who – or what
– this mask-wearing menace was, but naturally
kept that information secret from the wider
world.
Not that there was much point in keeping secrets
anymore; after all, there was hardly much
of a world left for the Foundation to hide
things from… and even fewer former personnel
who had lasted this long.
Even then, there was only a handful at the
SCP Foundation who knew everything that had
led to the current catastrophe.
Most of the researchers and guards had been
going about their ordinary duties, running
tests on contained anomalies or patrolling
the site where a certain, Possessive Mask
was housed.
The next thing everyone there knew was the
blaring noise of emergency alarms, Mobile
Task Force troopers racing down the hallways.
Their commander might have yelled something
about a break in, someone having gained access
to the supposedly secure Foundation facility
and stealing one of their anomalous objects.
But not everybody, even those working in the
same building, would have overheard that.
They definitely didn’t miss what happened
next, though.
As further alarms sounded, alerting the staff
on-site of a containment breach, the facility
itself was torn apart in a flurry of chaos.
Personnel – researchers, security, MTF soldiers
– were being incinerated, burned until there
was literally no trace of them left.
Something stepped through the very brickwork
of the building itself, smashing a hole through
every room it passed until it burst out of
the side.
Then, all of a sudden, the alarms weren’t
the loudest sound, something else started
deafening the Foundation staff who were still
standing.
The world outside had become even more chaotic;
the sky had turned red and, all around, people
were being killed, structures decimated, cities
blown away in moments.
Naturally, this wasn’t the first time the
Foundation had stared right into the face
of an XK Class end-of-the-world scenario.
Given the widespread presence and surveillance
they had around the planet, it didn’t take
them long to learn of the horrors that were
unfolding.
The key word there was that they had a widespread
presence, as in past tense.
They thought they had enough resources to
retaliate too.
Word quickly spread throughout the various
arms of the SCP Foundation, informing the
wider organization of the situation and urging
them to work as one to enact a plan to stop
what was happening.
All they knew for certain was that SCP-035
had been removed from containment.
Also known as the Possessive Mask, the object
was known to have its own sentience and an
innate ability to telepathically influence
unwitting victims into wearing it.
However, the mask also secreted a corrosive
black substance, which normally dissolved
the body of anyone who put it on.
By itself, SCP-035 was nowhere near powerful
enough to unleash a global catastrophe though.
Unfortunately, it had managed to influence
someone who was that powerful into putting
it on; another anomaly.
While, to the untrained eye, SCP-343 could
easily be mistaken for an elderly human man,
those at the Foundation knew that the fact
he was now wearing the Possessive Mask was
some of the worst news they could have ever
received.
Although none of the researchers working for
the SCP Foundation – in fact, not even the
O5 Council – knew if this was true, the
colloquial nickname for SCP-343 was ‘God’.
He not only claimed to be the sole creator
of the entire universe, but had also exhibited
extensive reality-warping abilities, advanced
even for an anomalous being.
His powers seemingly had no known limit in
how they could be used to alter the world
around him, although the old man himself seemed
to be a passive, kindly soul, rarely causing
active harm to other beings under normal circumstances.
Of course, normal circumstances didn’t include
having the corruptive SCP-035 on his face,
effectively putting the mask in the driver’s
seat, and allowing it to use SCP-343’s powers
to lay waste to anything before it.
The Foundation quickly diverted their considerable
assets to a brute force retaliation, in the
hopes that a full-scale assault on the combined
creature would somehow force a separation
of the Possessive Mask from SCP-343’s face.
The tricky thing about this situation was,
‘God’s powers and the fact that he was
an immortal, ageless being of potentially
incomprehensible form, all meant he couldn’t
be harmed.
Causing external damage to him was extremely
difficult.
That was good news in some regard, after all,
the Foundation didn’t want to kill 343 if
they could help it; they knew he wasn’t
acting of his own accord.
But his indestructibility also meant that
the corrosive goo that was secreted from SCP-035
had little to no effect on its new, impervious
host.
That meant it could keep going, keep unleashing
hell, and stopping it was going to take a
lot of manpower.
Fortunately, the SCP Foundation never had
any shortage of people to throw at a problem,
and their ethos didn’t really place much
value on human life.
They mobilized every Mobile Task Force at
their disposal, every one of them filled with
ranks of highly trained elite operatives.
Among the Foundation’s forces were even
MTF agents who had themselves been altered
through anomalous means, their bodies augmented
with technology and cybernetics, or their
strength specially enhanced.
Deploying the full might of their amassed
forces, the SCP Foundation took the fight
to SCP-035, with the goal of stopping its
reign of terror and freeing SCP-343 if possible.
The hybridized, mask-wearing reality warper
had already caused considerable damage since
it had started its rampage.
Although its motivations were far from political,
the Wearer of the Anguish Mask had begun with
a devastating show of power, wiping numerous
cities off the map.
While the rest of the world scrabbled to find
some way of responding, the Masked God teleported
itself across the globe, destroying the central
governments and further crippling their own
opportunities to initiate an armed response.
In short, this meant The Foundation’s move
was to be humanity’s last stand, their final
chance to stop SCP-035 from its current course
of harnessing the wise old man’s power to
turn the world into its own personal, nightmarish
playground.
To say there was a lot riding on the MTF assault
would be an understatement…
as would saying it went badly.
When met with times of defeat, the old, rather
morbid adage of fallen soldiers being ‘sent
home in bags’ is often applied.
But if the masked hybrid had sent the Foundation
its MTF troops back to them encased in body
bags, then that would have been far kinder
than what it actually did.
The collected Mobile Task Forces, the Foundation’s
own private army, were mobilized to Washington.
Under the influence of the Possessive Mask,
SCP-343 had wiped out not only the main seat
of power in the United States, but the Pentagon
as well, disabling the country’s defenses.
Suddenly, a mass of aerial transports and
ground vehicles came hurtling towards the
crater it had left behind; as it turned to
look, the wide grin of satisfaction on SCP-035
became a long frown.
Thanks to its new host's omniscience, it instantly
recognized the foot soldiers of the organization
that had kept it caged for so long.
As the amassed MTFs marched towards it, the
masked god stepped out to meet the oncoming
army; one being against thousands of troops
– if not tens of thousands.
If the mask had affixed itself to the face
of any other anomaly, those soldiers might
have stood a slim chance.
The combined creature casually raised the
bony arms of its host body, the Foundation
forces breaking into a charge the very second
that they saw it move.
Like a tidal wave, they rushed towards their
target, only for each individual operative
to quickly realize that they had stopped moving.
They were still running, legs still in motion,
but their feet had been lifted off the ground.
Plucked from the very earth they had each
stood on, the MTFs were stuck in mid-air,
defying the forces of gravity and unable to
free themselves.
Collectively, the Foundation’s army looked
to SCP-035, its tragic porcelain frown having
switched back to the wide grin, punctuating
the sick satisfaction it was about to take
from what came next.
It gave a click of God’s lean fingers, and
each of the MTF troops it had suspended in
mid-air were shredded at the molecular level.
Their bodies erupted with a spray of deep
red viscera, every one of them being pulled
to pieces from the inside out.
Flesh, bone, and blood melting away, breaking
down; becoming ash, then atoms, then nothing.
It took around a minute, not that it was terribly
exerting for SCP-343’s powers, but just
because of how many troops the Foundation
had sent to try and stop it.
A mighty show of force, and all for nothing.
With their Mobile Task Forces decimated like
a row of helpless tin soldiers, the SCP Foundation
had lost its primary method of fighting back.
But they were far from safe from the masked
god’s reach.
Thanks to its host, SCP-035 wasn’t all-knowing,
but all-seeing and able to be anywhere and
everywhere in the blink of an eye.
It began hunting the surviving pockets of
the Foundation’s personnel.
Out of nowhere, it would teleport into wherever
they were hiding and turn their bodies inside
out, or rearranging the functions of every
orifice on their faces, only to vanish like
a ghost, leaving no trace… and no survivors.
The braver ones tried desperately to come
up with some new plan, a revised way to stop
a creature that could be anywhere and do anything.
On the other hand, The Foundation leadership,
the more highly ranked members like the Overwatch
Council went to the ground.
Plenty of them had contingency plans in place
for Armageddon, and were prepared to wait
out the apocalypse in their own secluded,
safe haven.
But with the Foundation all but gone, that’s
when the monsters got loose.
No longer having anyone to guard them, to
maintain their specific, specialized containment
procedures, the SCPs still held at Foundation
sites were unleashed on the world.
Untold horrors came spilling out of the ruined
facilities, each one now acting as its own
Pandora’s Box, bursting its lock and having
its terrible contents lay waste to the planet
already awash with chaos.
A lot of the anomalies thrived in the world
that SCP-035 had created, once they were finished
fighting among themselves in the struggle
of escaping their containment.
d7f7db420598360e2837bb6ff8f6f5b840]
Soon, there were packs of SCP-745 running
wild on the ruined highways, using their bioluminescent
lights to hunt human survivors who were attempting
to make the dangerous trek across open country.
Meanwhile, a plague began spreading among
other camps of these post-apocalyptic humans,
a strange disease that seemed to cause people
to rapidly grow extra teeth, overproducing
them until SCP-4910, the Grinner, could catch
up to them.
Then, there were the SCPs that fled the nightmare
that the Masked God had made of the world.
Any that could travel between dimensions or
remove themselves from this layer of reality
quickly absconded to avoid the chaos.
Some just went about their business, as if
nothing had really changed.
The Plague Doctor mostly kept to himself,
traveling from place to place on foot, only
stopping when he encountered people afflicted
with the Pestilence, before moving on in search
of others.
Some of the anomalies tried to help people,
rumors spread among some survivor camps of
a half-man, half-cactus leaving them food
and supplies in the night, with a note that
read ‘From your friendly neighborhood Cactusman.’
There weren’t many who dared to oppose the
creator of this dark new world.
But some anomalies sought to challenge the
rule of this combined creature.
Perhaps they thought SCP-035 and SCP-343 couldn’t
possibly be as powerful as the stories said,
that it would be easy to kill the king and
assume control over his kingdom of chaos.
There were plenty of other anomalies that
had floated the idea, not just the other reality-warpers
but those that had figured out that if they
separated the mask from its host, then this
world would become their hellish paradise
to rule of – so long as SCP-343 didn’t
instantly undo all the damage.
But there was one that didn’t want control,
it didn’t even necessarily mind that the
whole world had been turned into a waking
nightmare.
It just wanted to stand against the hybrid
of malicious mask and all-powerful deity out
of spite, based on nothing but pure hatred
for any and all other forms of life other
than itself.
And it was that confrontation that would serve
as a warning to the rest of the SCPs now freely
roaming the world.
SCP-682 slithered out into the open, claws
coated with a fresh coating of blood from
its latest slaughter, wetting the countless
layers beneath that had already dried.
The Hard to Destroy Reptile had tracked the
scent of the Possessive Mask’s oozing black
secretions, bringing the beast maw-to-porcelain
face with the combined being responsible for
distorting the very fabric of the world.
Already knowing the foul lizard was near thanks
to its host’s foresight, SCP-035’s visage
had long been locked in that unhappy grimace,
dreading the approach of the day it would
have to face the tenacious, irritating regenerative
reptile.
It turned its host’s body to face the huge
beast, the trails of black streaked down its
frowning face looking like angry tears staining
its carved, off-white skin.
The two exchanged no words.
SCP-682 had no doubt this pairing of corruptive
mask and passive god already knew why it had
come looking for it.
And it was right, the Possessive Mask had
long been looking into the mind of SCP-343
to prepare.
It knew it wasn’t one of the old man’s
children, in fact, God had completely denied
ever being responsible for the creation of
the unkillable monster.
There was almost no strategy, even with the
infinite power of its hosts' reality-warping
abilities, that SCP-035 could definitively
kill SCP-682.
Building up to a charge, the reptile swiped
at the masked god, its talons narrowly nicking
the porcelain surface of the mask the very
second it teleported out of the way.
Reappearing behind the monster, SCP-035 compelled
its host body to lift its elderly arm and
decimate the beast the same way it had to
the Foundation forces.
With a fearsome hiss, the reptile’s body
was pulled apart.
It growled with anger, annoyed and enraged
more than deterred.
Its strong, scaly limbs quickly regenerated,
bone and muscle regrowing to replace what
the masked god had torn away.
SCP-682 gave a swipe of its tail, knocking
the masked god a few feet away, reeling him.
The anomalous hybrid teleported yet again,
this time to inside the monstrous reptile.
Shrinking down to almost infinitely small,
the mask and god wrenched apart SCP-682’s
atoms, ripping up strand after strand of its
very DNA, physically trying to unmake it on
a cellular level.
On the outside, the creature’s body disintegrated
as it roared, feeling its very genetic material
being broken down… only for it to rapidly
reform just as SCP-343, wearing SCP-035, reappeared
in front of it.
There was no way for the masked god to kill
the monster, despite how much it tried.
Sending it hurtling into the fire of the Sun,
punching it into other dimensions, moving
it down the recursive stack of reality to
make its existence little more than fiction.
Eventually, the Possessive Mask had to reconsider
the problem at hand.
Even with infinite power, the unkillable still
remained unkillable.
Rather than ask whether that meant its own
power was truly unlimited, it instead resolved
to the only option it had left.
With a snap of its host’s fingers, the combined
creature sent the Hard to Kill Reptile away.
Far away.
Universes upon multiverses of distance were
put between the masked god and SCP-682.
Turning back towards the destruction it had
wrought on this world, SCP-035 knew the regenerating
reptile would be back.
But for now, it had more chaos to unfurl.
Now go and check out “WHAT IF SCP-096 WORE
SCP-035?”
for another alternative anomalous outcome
of another SCP wearing the infamous Possessive
Mask!
And, if you haven’t already, then why not
watch the first installment of “WHAT IF
SCP-343 WORE SCP-035?”
to catch up on the story so far!